hello and welcome to this video playing
D n NV d n NV okay
you
you
yeah experimenting a little bit with
various with various deform opening
lines and here I've got the Torah check
and see what black is doing playing for
c5 setup sometimes white
has 95 I wonder if this is one of those
situations don't totally know this
opening too well
maybe that was true earlier
mmm-hmm it was a bit too early I guess
f6 now looks like a good timing for
black
it doesn't play that okay
oh okay there's a surprising weight of
way
sure about this
yeah I could you could think about
something more
recive even but
looks like a good solution you've got a
good knight on d4 and it's um this is
going to provoke weakness
six I would expect
g6 looks very weak on the dark squares
could still be played it's not
terribly bad and he plays it okay
you
Wow
it seems very confident in this screen
side and the screen side claim
this is going to be good to be a little
bit of an attack and not not so harmless
so it seems he wants to go with some age
six
stuff to say
in order to do this probably you need
the H pond
maybe I should have played a 3m too
maybe okay
now I don't need to play for a King side
attack necessarily can also play on the
D file
everything else failed it was age five
okay if everything else fails I can sort
claim to have the better minor piece
and claim it with some justification I
mean yeah I should insert this
it's not so easy my still desert okay
I wanted to say it's not so easy for him
to blame me for but he just did it
he just went for it
that's funny
so rook b8 he takes on the true I take
e8 King h7
my knight is unfortunately a little bit
a little bit far away
I'm just still still wait if I take rook
b8
you
Jesus you cannot 96 and he takes on
teach what's totally sick
now I mean I'm just better if I take I
mean I just tried to see if I can refute
this stuff I didn't see it this is
probably
like enough advantage to win because he
cannot move for anything yeah dark
squares are just totally dead and I have
rupees seven coming
I just felt they could be a tactical win
but I didn't see it
you
you
you
so who b7
and now probably community 8 now how do
we how do we win here
I cannot do this
[Music]
you
you
I don't see it knock out so let him make
a move it's not going to be so easy
you
very difficult to make a move to black
[Music]
threatening ec6 check-in c4s hanging
you
you
you
all right let's have a look there there
were some funny tactics that I feel as
interesting to explore I don't really
know this opening and I wonder if that
was if my play here was right I thought
that f6 should be fine I mean [ __ ] for
I don't know it might be okay as well
but I was a bit afraid that this is good
I was thinking that if five might be
Paso
engine dissing the cream thinks that
this is good for mind
on this one okay yeah maybe he has to
have time the seal Debenham
but it seems I wasn't in bad shape there
so the engine also likes this narrow 95
we do three castles eighth five
Bishop takes h7 ya has thought about it
but I didn't think it would work okay
and that's actually I just saw that I
don't have a check here but there is
rook F 3 g3 look at this
and who gets three Wow
engines has made in 13 that's great
okay very windy wind a queen
yeah that is amiss then yeah I played
this too quickly I was quite happy about
this strategically so I didn't really
look that much but we should make seven
was such a standard idea that I should
investigate it
okay rook FB 8 I've heard was surprising
okay I will with the rope here yeah no
Queen trade of course cringe e7h form
Knight e4 and 94 I felt was it was very
surprising that he would allow this
transformation I was surprised by that
after before it's tense I mean I was
thinking my attack must be quite strong
but I was thinking him and maybe we
should a form but he is six is probably
the problem right
mage six we never aid
and five some something like that is
quite dangerous
you know them the engine evaluation is
climbing up it must be dangerous at
least I mean this King is under severe
pressure okay when he played 94 and I
took it and this must be it must be
better for Wyatt by quite a bit she ate
III seems kind of useful and it's still
played before now this is interesting I
would like to check this takes takes
takes and now he took one c3 I was
thinking but it's something where it is
not so easy to do I thought first of all
I calculated this but then C takes D to
is possible it seems but it is actually
winning okay this this teenage - and
white wins this position yeah well hmm
no squares and here you can do this
and why do we
the attack amazing
Wow
yeah the key line is this you get this
back no you probably I can also just
take there's twin pawns I'm from like
three pawns of him okay what I did
calculate is this this this this this
and here I thought I mean I cannot stop
the Queen yeah the Queen will appear on
d1 but I thought that might be winning
but I couldn't quite figure it out
I was thinking 96 for example could win
that is a transposition yeah to what we
had the form but I couldn't really
figure it out it seems however that if I
go rookie 7 here
let him promote with check and here that
this is a winning winning idea
[Music]
so it's quite remarkable cringy form
take-take-take I mean this is God knows
he's got to squeeze it's just it's just
a remarkably bad position
yeah like this okay so I had a hunch
that this wins but I thought this should
just win technically and I think I'm
right down that yet you cannot hold it
just plus for me without any any
problems and here are king edge to is
one of the would motions engine gives it
as well like it's just running out of
moves if you have no moves simply that
you can play this is now fairly fairly
single win yeah it's so interesting I
think this is the key moment he should
not play 94 currently my bishop is not
even that great on c2 and his Knight
it's just a source of county plant
allowing that trait is definitely yeah
more favorable for me straight okay guys
thanks for watching